there's about a 20-plus minute straight
action sequence that also moves the plot
forward
and i think people miss that and this is
like at the end the culmination where
the vampires pull up on the
on the likens and because victor is now
awakened and knows what's about to
happen and they want to get michael
in this scene there's so much between
craven
and victor and michael and it all goes
down and you also get
celine doing like a double flip off of
someone
killing two lichens straight in the
street while she's going to get michael
so i just i think we can't underesti we
can't
talk about enough that the fact that
they just shot 20 minutes plus
of just straight battle and then also
in those minutes talking about what
jacqueline just talked about which is
giving the history of the love story
yep i i i don't
i'm not i'm not feeling the love story
as any sort of compelling
avenue in this movie and it's not going
to but
would you it's it's be it's not because
i don't have a heart jack when you know
that i can watch a movie like definitely
maybe and immediately be like oh okay i
could do a 10 year old
i guess i could have someone in my life
like that but with this
and it's not that i don't understand the
metaphor for
racial relations and the fact that this
might be an interracial relationship
it's just that i don't care and i feel
like celine is just grasping at straws
looking for a dude i don't think that
this guy's the dude i think that he's a
guy
that happened to show up and she
is gonna rescue him she's gonna have all
the power in the relationship and i just
i think that he is the maybe mister
right now i just don't i never felt like
he was mr right for celine
look with people like craven which first
of all
worst naming in the history i'll give it
to them on some of the names and this
are awesome but
big shocker yeah the the dude named
craven turns out to be a cowardly master
who they originally like lauded as their
like hero and i'm like who
thought that this was believable dude
named craven is supposed to be the hero
whatever craven
also gave us the only issue i find with
the movie
is the lack of um
moving forward the sex scene in the
vampire the vampire sex deserved more
we were not given the proper vampire sex
um and i blame craven
yeah they gave it to us in the sequels
but i agree
i i always think it's gonna be awesome
if i'm watching a vampire movie and the
love making is about to commence i'm
like this is gonna be such a cool scene
there's gonna be biting it's gonna be
blood it's gonna be passionate
and in the middle of it i just feel like
you know what this
i feel weird i feel like i need a bath
after watching this i feel like
they're gonna turn into bats and now i'm
just watching bats mate like it's
national geographic and it just
vampire love scenes have a lot of
promise very little payoff for this guy
but again
i'm just a mere human speculating on
what a relationship of an entirely
different species is like
in this case if you had the virus that
turned you into
a vampire or i'll say this i'd rather
watch werewolves
make love than vampires is that a hot
[Music]
take
[Music]
you